Yeah, I'm sorry if you have no if you have no evidence and it's
like actually um people are really unhinged and somebody found
my address and I didn't keep any evidence of this, but also cuz
I'm I'm like moving and like uh I'm not worried about that guy
having my name apparently or anything to that he would have used
to find my address. I'm just mostly worried about well I can't
really tell you what I'm worried about. >> Actually had
looked this up a few days ago because I heard Naruto Eridite
which is another one of like criminal associates. I think this
is like the Galain Maxwell. >> No way. Hold on. Part two,
Destiny, Thought Crimes, and Assand Derangement Syndrome. I actually
had looked this up a few days ago because I heard Naro Eridite,
which is another one of Pestany's like criminal associates. I
think this is like the Galain Maxwell of Destiny's community,
right? Is this is that her or is that a different person?
to say, I'm an individualist. I don't care about race. I don't
think race is real. Well, you're the beneficiary of race. Your
career is built on race. Your career is built on white guilt.
>> So, it's super convenient and I'm happy for you that
you have moved beyond race and you are enlightened. But your
whole life,
your marriage, your wife, your life, all of it is built on white
guilt. White people thinking they need a black woman to tell
them to feel okay about voting Republican. White people feeling
the need to fill a diversity quota. That's what that is. You
are a diversity hireer. You are a DEI hireer. You pander,
you know, and she thinks she's some kind of boss.
Yeah, you're a But like you you didn't get that way because you're
a super smart boss. You got that way because you're a you're
super black token. Like it is what it is. So >> I don't
know that anyone's ever told her >> Okay. You don't think
Candace Owens has ever been told that? >> I feel like that
is the prevailing popular opinion on the internet is that basically
all of that is true. as as much as it is kind of like a racist
thing. I don't believe anybody would suggest that Candace Owens
has never been told that before. >> But um that's just
that's the obvious with and I'm kind of done with all the Uncle
Tom's in a way. I'm done with all the Uncle Tom's. I'm done with
Jason Whitlock. I'm done with Candace Owens. I'm done with all
the Uncle Tom token blacks. Like you're not that smart. You're
you're not even that conservative.
You built your career on a griff that is now dead. You were hired
when diversity quotas were a thing. You were hired when white
guilt is a thing. I don't feel white guilt. I never have. DEI
is over. So now you're done. You need to be fired. Like you're
done. So I respect the black people that have actually earned
their stripes. People like Myron Gaines
who >> He didn't ever get any favorability for being black.
He got cancelled, you know.
um, this while this is proving that Nick Fentes is a big fan.
I need we at some point for like a Patreon stream or something.
I'm going to go cover that. I'm going to find that Sneo Myin
Zurka Nick Fuentes VOD. Okay. Where they talk about where they
run down like the entire history of like Renaissance era Europe
to show how power moved around different countries, right? And
and Myin is like not missing a single beat. Myron is like explaining
when when Nick like falters, Myron's right there to pick up like
like they're finishing each other's sentences. Okay, we're going
to go watch that stream and then I'm going to say, "Guys, you
really think that this guy hates as much as Hamp does?" Obviously
not. I trust I trust these guys with with the button to genocide
way more than Hassan. My is probably Arab. Myin is from uh North
Africa. Yeah, he is Arab. He would be Arab. Yeah, I forget which.
I forget he's if he's from uh Oh, what is it? Mon uh not Morocco.
Maybe he might be from No, Sudan. Sudan. Yeah, he's Sudan. >> I
just had enough of >> Oh, sorry. This clip's done. Let's
see if this is it. This is almost certainly >> much about
Hassan though. He's like Hassan Ra who would genocide like I
think Myron would genocide before. I'm I'm dead serious about
that. >> No. Does he think I would deny that? Well, actually.
>> Oh, yeah. No. So, Oh, wait. I was like, "Oh, he just
has the correct opinion.
He just has the exact
correct opinion." And then Oh, wait. Hold on. Hold
I don't know. Actually, that would actually be a hard one cuz
>> Would it Would it be a hard one? Would it actually be
a hard one? >> I'm really It's hard to say actually. I'm
not sure. Actually, I think that in a weird way, I think that
the race realist people and like the white supremacist people,
which I is somehow in the crowd of, would probably be less likely.
Uh, no. Here's the thing. The reason why Fentes says that he
wouldn't genocide people is because he's a Christian and he and
a Catholic and he believes in the sanctity of all human life
and and souls. Myin is a Muslim. And what do Muslims think about
warfare? And do they think they're at war broadly? Is it a broad
cultural belief that Muslims or Arabs are at war with
You think Marin's not pressing that button, bro? >> Okay.
Actually, you know what? I will say Myron's not necessarily sincere
in his uh Muslim belief, okay? His Islamic >> Actually,
you know what? I don't think that's true because I think that
Myron's position ultimately, my guess would be Myron's position
ultimately would be, listen, I don't want to support Israel and
their control over the United States. Maybe we genocide all the
in the US or at least get them the out. And if they want to do
in Israel, them don't deserve our support. No, that's definitely
not. No, no, no. That's definitely not.
Come on,
bro. Oh,
I don't think he is serious in most of his positions or sincere
in this position. In the the position, he literally lost the
highest earning super chat show on YouTube for his the
just to be able to say the you understand that that's insane,
right?
that like the the hill he died on was the that's the hill he
died on. That that should be allowed as speech on YouTube. That's
why he lost the highest super chat earning show on all of YouTube,
right? How did Destiny blur out the obvious answer and then walk
it back? Walked off a cliff. I have no idea, bro. No, no, no,
no, no.
This is
This is crazy.
This is insane. That would be Myron's position. Hassan would
go further and say we should support the Palestinians in the
eradication of of all the Jews in the Israeli state and and turn
it into one state solution. I think but hold on is Destiny Wait,
Destiny, you understand? Even if that were true, that would make
them about equal. No, because we know for a fact Hassan would
not advocate for any annihilation of in America, right? At worst,
at the absolute worst at the most unhinged you could possibly
think Hassan is, he would say, "Okay, we uh we're going to bomb
Israel. We're going to bomb Israel because they've they've persecuted
the Palestinian people. We're at war with Israel, right? That's
like the worst Hassan could possibly be. He's not Jews in America.
But by the way, that would also be insane to believe that Hassan
would just immediately genocide all in Israel. That would also
be insane. But but at worst, like the population, I believe,
is roughly equivalent between both. Yes. Yeah. Is he actually
defending My He's full on spite based? Yeah, he is. Dude, my
is not like joking around with the anti-semitism stuff. Byron
believes like fully fully entirely like people control the media,
people control America. Like and I don't believe he just thinks
it's Israeli either. I think he believes it's like it's crazy.
Destiny spite. No, he would never. Dude, it's all spitebased.
It's bro.
I'm going to back it up. He's basically saying hates the even
less less than Han. I don't know if that's quite there. realist
people and like the white supremacist people which I is somehow
in the crowd of would probably be less likely actually you know
what I actually you know what that is actually hold on this might
actually be true
believes that Pixie is just a gold digging right is that truly
where Destiny's getting this opinion from he's willing to overlook
you know complete conspiracy brain right like the most conspiracy
brain person on Twitter one of the like top 10 most conspiracy
brain people on Twitter is not anti-Semitic, not more anti-Semitic
than Hassan.
It must entirely be because, you know,
must be because of the Pixie. That's the That's the difference,
right? It's the Pixie position. Asan supports Pixie. My is like
she's a gold digging. Don't listen to her. Wow.
I don't think that's true because I think that Myin's position
ultimately, my guess would be Myron's position ultimately would
be, listen, I don't want to support Israel and their control
over the United States. Maybe we genocide all the Jews in the
US or at least get them the out and if they want to do in Israel
them they don't deserve our support. That would be Myron's position.
Hassan would go further and say we should support the Palestinians
in the eradication of of all the in the Israeli state and and
turn it into one state solution. I think actually Hassan would
go further there. You can actually have him on both debate because
because generally like the usually Hassan isn't Hassan is not
arguing for a one-state solution. Sorry. He is that's not what
I meant. Sorry. Hassan is not arguing technology. Right. One
state solution is not killing the Jews. [__] I
wheel it back. Wheel it back. One state solution is not blaming.
He wants to kill the Jews. It's not him wanting to kill the It's
him saying democracy is like my highest principle, right? Like
one person, one vote. That is what he's saying. It's an it's
a naive position, but it is not a genocidal position. Clip it
and ship it. No, I pulled it back. Come on. Yeah, it's a it's
a naive position. It's not a genocidal position. If you if you
said what if what if there if you just gave Hassan this hypothetical
you go what if uh the were at significant risk of being killed
if that happens right he would go oh you might have to wait you
might have to delay it or something right if you if you just
knocked down the walls in Gaza and you just like you just made
it one state immediately overnight probably there'd be violence
done to people right almost certainly there'd be violence done
to people but I don't think anybody's really arguing for like
tomorrow it has to be one person one vote there'd be violence
done to Palestinian people too just so we're But uh there'd be
like a lot of fighting. They would they would be at each other's
throats like pretty quickly.
I believe some people don't believe that. Dude, the destiny really
just took the position that he would trust he would trust the
the well-being of all on planet Earth to my gains over
This is perhaps some of the most baffling I've ever seen. By
the way, if you want to send clips, put them in
content suggestions or stream chat. Either one, guys. Okay?
Either one.
The perspective as strange as it is is not actually the genocide
of the it's the idea that are the ones the Zionist occupied government
are the ones controlling the government and you need to eliminate
all that influence and stop supporting Israel. No, that's the
that's like the Fentes position and that's probably that's probably
the mask like he would argue he would have argued for sure like
a year ago that that's the mask on Fuentes position, right? That's
that's like the that is like the mask on Fuentes position. We
need out of power. We don't need to kill them. We just need them
out of power in America and then whatever, right? But that's
not really that ah man that's not like
he would argue a year ago that that's Fuentes with Mascot and
Fentes does want to genocide all the Jews. Myin believes I I
think that the ethnicity is like evil like at a base level like
they've been doing evil across all of Europe for thousands of
years, right? That they've they've just been evil for all this
time. Why would you need to include all that stuff before Israel
exists? Why would you have so many bad beliefs about Jewish people
from before Israel existed if it was only about Israel and the
influence over the American government? Why? Why would you need
any of that? Almost like something we should think about.
That's their perspective generally. It's like an isolationist
view at least with regards to Israel. Assad I think would go
a step further. Like Myron Gaines is not out here ardently supporting
the Palestinians. He just hates the the the US association with
Israel. He definitely doesn't think Israel does bad things in
that region. He definitely doesn't think Israel is like a
dude.
Listen, maybe maybe Hey, I don't have that pause. >> He
just hates the the the US association with Israel. He hates like
the subversive nature, by the way. Doesn't just think Zog. He
thinks like absolutely like Zog media,
right? Zogged social media, Zog traditional media, Zog everything.
It's like Zog all the way down. It's not just like, oh, Apac
needs to get out of our politics and that'll be okay. It's not
like that. It's not like that, bro. Oh, a cursed guardian.
Oh my god.
Oh my god. This is honestly,
if it's not spite, this is the next best explanation.
This is like a Lauren Southern tier
sanewashing the likes of which we've never seen before. Okay,
that's the next best explanation.
That is the only thing that could explain it. Okay, my self-hating
enough. Hey, I think that's that's the only thing I can think
of. That's the only thing I can think of. How did How do we get
here? Is he done?
>> And I think I'm not that I'm not that I that I maybe
right. I don't know. I I'm not I don't I don't share that confidence.
I I >> I have to leave in two minutes. Hold on. I'm going
to my kickstream and transition in a second. Let me finish watching
a little bit more of this. >> You could be right. Um but
I have suspicions that it might be the other way around. You
think my gates obn
but Pisco's laughing because Pisco doesn't know any of the underlying
political ideologies. Pisco couldn't tell you what's the difference
between MAGA and a Nazi or what's between like a white supremacist
um versus like a like a white identitarian/isolationist.
Um what's the difference between like a modern race realist versus
like the hardcore prior like um like the like the crazy racial
like eugenicists?
Like just doesn't know the difference between any of these. Like
in his mind he's like
>> Destiny is totally making up the difference between
these. Destiny has totally totally made up the difference between
these. Dude, no way. No way. >> Laughing because Pisco
doesn't know any of the underlying political ideologies. Destiny
thinks that Myron Gaines and Nick have like the exact same view
of
right? They have a lot of overlapping views, but the thing that
keeps Nick from advocating for genocide is not the thing that
is not something Myron's concerned about. >> Couldn't tell
you what's the difference between MAGA and a and a what's between
like a >> You don't think Pisco could tell you the difference
between MAGA and a Guys, I don't think Pisco could tell me the
difference between Charlie Kirk and Nick
That seems like a reasonable position. That seems totally like
it doesn't that Oh, yeah, sure. This guy who spends all day talking
about politics probably can't tell you the difference between
Nick Fuentes, well I wouldn't even say Nick Fentes is an necessarily
if you want to say like Christian nationalist ethnist, right?
It's there's slight differences there. >> White supremacist
um versus like a like a white identitarian isolationist. Um what's
the difference between like a modern race? >> That that
would be one that would be a little bit different. Somebody says,
"Oh, I'm a white nationalist versus a white ethnicist or isolationist."
There would be differences there, but it's all in the words.
Everything there >> realist versus like >> sorry,
everything in the label there is is all you need to explain it.
>> The hardcore prior like um like the like like the crazy
racial like eugenicists like because she doesn't know the difference
between any of these like in his mind like oh anti-semitism is
anti-semitism. Some people are more anti-semitic than other people.
Like it's not
>> I have suspicions that it might be the other way around.
You think my gains
>> You can say that in a high pitch voice
like really like again I again I don't know I don't have a strong
leaning but I would it surprise me? >> I don't think I
bet a lot of money on it but I yeah I would assume that like
I don't All they're going to do by the way this this entire thing
right here is
I I don't know for sure about Avi, right? But for Destiny all
he's doing is saying this, right? He's going to say this like,
"I don't know which one I trust more." And then he's going to
get the clips of of Myra's actually like beliefs and he's going
to go, "Oh, whoops.
Whoops. Whoops." I wouldn't say, "You know what? No, I shouldn't
even let Avy let me head share." And I think if I talked to Aby,
I think Abby would agree. Um, I think I would be significantly
more likely than Myron to engage in any kind of like foreign
genocidal action against people. Oh,
look at the save. Look at the save. after everything he says
that oh he'd be more likely to like genocide foreign Jews. Okay.
I mean he already admitted the whole thing. He's expecting that
to be a part of the clip for people not to watch the whole thing.
Right. So the argument now is what he's trying to save here is
like no I think Hassan would like actually hurt Israel a lot
more. And I don't think that's even arguable. But that's not
what he said. That's not the original hypothetical he went into.
And it is not even covered by his original statements of like
oh my would like all the the in America, right?
So his original thing that he said is like, "Oh, would would
Hassan be safer for people overall on the in the world or would
Myron?" That's that's a crazy walk back right in the in the same
thing without saying he was wrong. >> Asan would genocide
before Myron. Um, but look, regardless, the point I'm trying
to illustrate is just the sense of anger that someone might feel
if they were to see something analogous. >> Would Myron
not hurt Israel, too? I don't understand. He doesn't I don't
believe Myron thinks it's Israeli influence in media. I don't
think Myron's beliefs stop at Israel.
I'm pretty sure they don't. In fact, I'm pretty confident they
don't stop at Israel. It's like the people the entire time they've
existed on this planet, 109 countries can't be wrong. 108 108
countries about to be 109. That's like the level Myron's operating
on, right? He does not believe Isra Israel is a symptom of the
actual problem.
That is Myron's belief. I do not believe Hassan's got anything
like that. That Israel is like the symptom of the
like that. And whether he's being consistent or not is not really
the the sort of question I'm answering. It's just conveying that
sort of you're I'm just answering your question >> of what
completely unh some of the most insane positions I've ever seen
in context hanging out with those sorts of >> But then
I would also distinguish someone like Crystal Ball. >> I
don't know. We'll see. I'll probably watch it >> because
your second part of your question was is there something deeper?
>> Okay. Okay. We're gonna watch all of that later, I think.
Hold on. People are sending more clips because I do want to watch
the long form versions of some of these things. What is this?
What is this? What is this? What is this? >> Is it? It
is. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, you were open to talk
to him anytime, right? >> I've said a million times like
me and Hassan and Bosch could even if we were doing antagonistic
content, it would be amazing content. These are million view
videos every single debate. It would be crazy. And if we were
doing >> Wait, did he not know Hassan's position on Israel
in November 29th, 2024?
Wow. November 29th, 2024, 3 days after the videos of him went
live, he's like, "Hey guys, I could totally do content with Vos
and and Hassan." 100% right now, guys. 100%.
Synergistic content, bro. the like me and Hassan and Vosch having
like a competition between like how many people we could get
to like post pictures of voting at booths or whatever like the
the amount of synergy there would be it would be unbelievable.
We're the three largest I think like of all like the live streamers.
I'm pretty sure we're the three largest live streamers for politics
on the internet like not just like podcast. I think it's me and
Hassan. Cool guys >> all of us are on the >> So what
changed in Hassan's P in Hassan position on Israel since November
29th
I wonder, sorry, not position on Israel, his positions on everything,
his positions on America, his positions on communism.
Did his entire ideology change in eight months?
In eight months, his entire ideology changed so can't be trusted.
>> Hold on, let me go back and just start it again.
>> Is it? >> It is. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
So, you are open to talk to him anytime, right? I've said a million
times like me and Hassan and Vosch could even if we were doing
antagonistic content, it would be amazing content. >> Oh,
this person right here, Drowslayer, this total [__]
just said he said
Apparently didn't listen listen past that. Hold on. Even if it
was antagonistic content, it would be amazing. What does he mean
even if these are million view videos every single debate? It
would be crazy. And if we were doing synergistic content,
>> what does synergistic mean? Does that mean like working
together towards a goal? Like he was totally open towards to
to working together towards a goal with Hassan and Bosch.
That's Wow, guys. That's crazy. I wonder what has changed in
the past 8 months. Certainly, it must be Hassan's entire ideology
was revealed to Destiny within the past 8 months,
Yeah. No cooking a pizza. We just saw it in 8K, guys. We just
saw it in 4K and 8K and 240 FPS. We just added 240 FPS, guys.
Oh my god, sorry. Didn't mean to add the the total sped moment
there. Okay, bro. The like me and Hassan and Vosch having like
a competition between like how many people we could get to like
post pictures of voting at booths or whatever. Like the the amount
of synergy there would be it would be unbelievable. We're the
three largest I think like of all like the live streamers. I'm
pretty sure we're the three largest live streamers for politics
on the internet. Like not just like podcast. I think it's me,
Vos, and Asan. All of us are on the left, but >> we don't
do any content together. None of us do. That's crazy. So I What
are >> Guys, it's crazy that Destiny and Hassan and Bosch
don't all do content together. Isn't that crazy?
Isn't that crazy? It's almost like something happened between
now and November 29th that made Destiny unpalatable to most people
where they don't want to do any collaborations with him. And
suddenly uh his entire like spitefueled complex with regards
to politics and interpersonal relationships kicked in and he
started burning everybody he can. Wow. I didn't think I'd think
I'd get like I didn't think there was like shot proof like that
just sitting out here. But who' have thought >> Yeah, it's
it's legit stupid actually. So I'm like I thought >> I
don't even need more Paul's ego. That's crazy.
That's crazy chat. That's
bro. How do you dude? How do you How did that happen? How did
How did he take these positions with like comments like this
out there? That's nuts. Don't play it. Well,
that's crazy, Chad. There it is, CeCe. All right, cool. Thank
you very much for the clip. That was uh very interesting. So,
we go from Destiny saying Myin is better for the than Hassan.
And then 8 months ago, he's advocating for him, Vos, and Hassan
after the election, by the way, to do synergistic content together.
To do synergistic content together. It's almost like you can't
take anything this guy says seriously in any way.
Crazy. >> Suspect there probably is. >> Oh, whoops.
Okay, guys. Let's finish up the Hassan video. We'll finish up
the Hassan video and then maybe we'll look at Destiny trying
to fight with the Discord again. I'm not totally sure which direction
we're going to go in after this, but I'm going to play this water
going over >> When I do that Destiny impression, my voice
gets up. So, I need more water so I don't totally run it run
it ragged. >> To point out the bad faith in the Destiny
clip before Hassan has ever even given his answer. He's asking
his chat for a clip of someone else talking about re-education.
He then just asserts Hassan is lying. Plays the clip of someone
else. >> Quick reach out. I am not on my primary account.
So, Kger, you'd have to get him to reach out through a different
account. Okay, hold on. Let me let me just grab this really quickly
here. I'll send this to you. Creger if you want to if you can
uh get him to add me or I'll add him actually. I'm guessing he's
just Wick TV, right? That's me. I'll add him if he wants to talk.
Wick TV.
I sent him a friend request. Does it have It's got his thing.
He left my server. You son of a Wick. Go through the Destiny
Reddit. It's basically rape review content. Okay. Okay. Okay,
guys. I need to use the bathroom real quick. I will be right
back. Uh, if somebody could clip that last segment though, just
the my god that needs to be posted. That's wild, dude. That's
wild.
Talking about the reeducation camps and says this is what Hassan
actually wants. The clip has someone basically saying people
should be put into reeducation camps for thought crimes that
go against socialism. Hassan clearly does not advocate for that
and rejects the idea of it as bad. He only advocated as uh for
re-education as a tool for dradicalization of ideological violent
criminals and terrorists and to make it a part of the rehabilitation
process of replacement for Americanstyle prisons. I just that's
precisely my point by the >> All right, maybe we'll talk
to Wick in just a second. We'll see what's what's happening
and yeah, depending on what he's doing and then yeah, I'll still
haven't walked away. I'm sending messages trying to get things
to happen.
>> we're doing it. Space Ghost, thank you for the Thank
you for the two gifted subs. Really appreciate it. Guys, we are
if you like the content, go ahead, donate a little bit, donate
a little bit. Okay,
donate, donate, donate. Extra time on the stream. We need all
the hours we can tonight. I started as early as I could so we
can get through all this content. Okay, you need to donate now.
I'm going to use the bathroom and get some water. I'll be right
back. I'll be right back. Hold on. I walked away and I didn't
hit play on the video. What am I doing? And I advocate for that
within a within the framework of liberal capitalist democracy
as well for like white suprists. I think it's an important facet
of rehabilitation.
Okay.
Destiny even poisons the welfare people who interpret differently
what Hassan is saying by demeaning them as regarded fans. I I
assume this a substitute for the rword. I have never once in
my life ever watched Hassan as a form of entertainment. Like
99% of my consumption of Hassan has been through either Destiny,
Sitch, and Adam. and the other 1% has been fact-checking what
other people say Hassan said. I don't really know that much more
about Assan's politics. In the past, I had looked up a few statements
about Hassan that Dan Saltman said that also turned out to be
mostly lies. Pisco has been calling out more of the lies that
come from this community. Mostly lies involving himself, and
I hope he continues to do so in other ways that narratives are
misconstrued from there. Part three. Nonserite caught the Hassan
derangement syndrome terminal. This is going to be slightly discombobulated
because I want to finish this and I've spent too much time on
it already. I wanted to include a clip of her making this claim
to show that more people from DG just believe whatever narrative
Destiny spins up. And because she goes beyond just accusing him
of advocating for re-education camps, she doesn't just think
that Assan wants them, but wants them for political speech he
doesn't like and claims he is similar to Trump in that way and
would be just as authoritarian, if not more so than the Bro.
Okay, I'm back. Okay, dude. I can't believe that clip. I actually
cannot believe that clip. Okay,
that clip is crazy. Sorry, but I it didn't strike me that like
Destiny's entire derangement towards Hassan is like almost entirely
driven by him having these things go public, the Pixie stuff
go public, the Jerry stuff go public, and his reputation being
torched that it's actually not to do with like any principal
position against collabing with people. It's not to do with any
principal position against Marxists, Marxist Leninists, anything
like that. It is entirely spitebased
based on people walking away from him. Pisco had no idea how
right he was. Pisco is like Destiny has a problem with me because
I walked away from him, right? It's all entirely personal, petty,
spite. It's not anything to do with my political positions. But
it turns out Destiny's positions towards everybody, all content
creators, right? Is just spite based and and him lashing out
at people who don't want to collab with him anymore.
That's crazy. The orange man. She also thinks Asmin Gold is better
than Han as a content creator for young men. not really important
to my post but shows the terminal nature of the Hassan derangement
syndrome. Like this is this is something that I have noticed
as well. A lot of these like liberal supposedly liberal content
creators are shephering their audience to find right-wing content
creators like Asmin Gold to be more permissible and better overall
than someone like myself because they've designed their entire
worldview around like saying Hassan and Hassan is so scary. Dude,
the the other the thing that they're like twisting like as Oh,
we should we should totally align with Asmin Gold actually. Dude,
Destiny from eight months ago. Destiny from November 2024 would
have like cut the head off of any one of his chatters immediately.
That chatter would have been gone if they suggested uh Hassan
over Asmin Gold. Sorry, Asmin Gold over Hassan. My >> And
that's the reason why you see so many of these like accounts
that go along with these insane narratives.
That's literally I mean that's just insane. That's just insane.
I mean I don't even know where to begin but like Asmin Gold is
pro Trump at its most base, right? At his most basic approach,
he is proTrump. So if you're a liberal in this regard, why are
you saying that he would be better overall
than than someone like myself for like dradicalizing the youth?
>> Hard to say.
I can't I honestly can't think of a reason. >> Yes, you're
right. It's not a conspiracy. I mean, this is this basically
lays it out. Do you have a disagreement with the way that this
stuff is presented or do you just want to say, "Oh, it's just
a conspiracy." I don't think it's like a conspiracy theory necessarily.
>> People fighting back against that post is so funny.
It's like so funny to watch people fight back against that post.
Like, you actively have to deny reality to fight against that
r/pisco post.
It's just how things are. Do not fight reality. reality will
always win.
>> I think there are ideological differences between someone
like myself and someone like someone like all of his orbiters.
For sure, I get that. I understand that. The problem is we're
not actually having a conversation on ideological differencation.
We're not even having a conversation. is just basically someone
consistently going through meticulously
through every single thing that I've said and misrepresenting
it in the most uh potentially the most negative way possible
while simultaneously
presenting someone who is directly a right-wing far-right individual
as a better alternative. I mean this is we saw this already and
the reason why we're have he had to skim over parts of it he
skimmed over the part Hassan did not skim over. Okay, read the
not soite stuff. Oh, wait. He skimmed over the voting thing,
which actually gives away his pre-watch, but with Asan. Um,
he just said the he just said the part that we don't say out
loud sometimes. Gay. He's just like, "Oh, isn't this like his
Gain Maxwell?" >> Having this conversation is because of
this. It unfolded with this massive apparently massive debate
amongst like the liberal content creators that debate everything
including whether or not I would be worse than Adolf or Donald
Trump as a pres as the president. Do you know what I mean? I
mean this is a deeply unserious hypothetical to begin with. I'm
a Twitch streamer. I think that there is like uh you know I don't
command that much influence or attention. But also my world view
is directly outside of both of the major political parties in
a way where I would say Nick Fuentes and his views are not directly
outside of either of the major political parties. Nick Fuentes
is a lot closer to Donald Trump in his world view with one very
big exception which is you
>> Nick Fentes would not think that. I think Nick Fentes
is about to debate Alex Jones on this that like Trump is not
the way forward anymore. Trump has >> hating people and
claiming that people are controlling American politics. But outside
of that, they are fairly aligned on most of the issues, which
is precisely the reason why he can, you know, go and have dinner
with Donald Trump alongside Kanye West. >> You agree or
disagree with what he just said that Fuentes is closer? I think
Fentes is I think to like how Trump campaigned maybe Fuentes
is closer. Fuentes would be very upset about this because Fuentes
would say that Donald Trump said he'd get Israel in line, no
more foreign wars, uh fixing immigration, and Fuentes would say
he hasn't done any of that.
Um, as far as Trump aligning with people or sorry, Hassan aligning
with people, I mean, Hassan was invited to the DNC. Fuentes is
banned from the RNC and like all associated conservative events.
So, I don't know how like it's it's just depend it depends on
like what avenue you want to compare them on, right? Hassan is
more accepted or is has been courted by the Democratic party
in a way that Fuentes has been totally rejected. But I don't
know if but Fentes's com conduct is just different too. Like
Fuentes like straight up harasses Charlie Kirk, right? Like that's
how he broke into the scene. So man, it's it's really hard to
analyze it as a straight up one to one in terms of ideology.
Who's closer to the party leader?
Fentes is probably closer to Trump,
especially like Hassan probably does have some hard leftist beliefs,
right? that I don't think would line him up with like Biden.
Maybe Camala. I'd say Passan is closer to Camala if she'd won.
Kamala rather >> for example. Whereas my position is unfortunately
not very close to the Democratic party. I wish it was and I wish
the Democrats would actually advocate for more
radical solutions which aren't even radical at all. They're just
better overall uh for >> Hold on. Quick update guys. Destiny
thinking my is less likely to genocide the is either actual Hassan
derangement syndrome or an inadvertent whitewashing of how psychoin
actually is. This isn't a result. This isn't a defense of Assad,
but his argument that Hassan's advocacy for a one-state solution
would automatically result in the genocide of well admitting
my would genocide the in America but leave the Jews in Israel
alone just came across as incredibly stupid.
Yes.
Also, I don't know if Yeah, I don't know. People asking for a
time stamp. Also, this is the a turbo honeypot thread and that'll
that I'll probably get banned for. 07. This guy knows. This guy
knows his attitude towards my is unhinged. Asmin and teen combined
are 10 times better than Myin. Uh yeah, but he's kind of courting
those guys as well. So, feel like he's way too friendly to that
guy. Okay. I thought of the same logic when Pisco said that.
Not going to deny Destiny is probably also motivated by contrarianism,
but here's my thoughts. Oh, somebody's trying to do it. He's
going to He's going to do it. He's going to humiliate himself
publicly. I see it. I see it. Got to defend it, guys. As he takes
on white nationalists in in general is off base. In their utopia,
they would absolutely at the very least exile all Jews in the
US. So, this is the general line on Fentes is like, oh, the idea
that they wouldn't kill these people or or like uh yeah, it wouldn't
result in mass violence is crazy, right? That it's a mask on
version when they say they just don't want them in power or something.
Myron is unserious and de treats him as such.
No, Myron is not unserious. Myin is not unserious. Myin is one
of the most serious anti-semites in the world. Okay, Myron is
an incredibly serious anti-semite. Myron is not around when it
comes to anti-semitism. Myin learns from all the greats. Okay,
he is a scholar of anti-semitism. I have one of the biggest Assad
haters out there was an H3 fan who started realizing that he
was really likely or really like even or what he was really like
rather before he even left leftovers.
And I am and I would choose Hassan as emperor of the US over
Myin as a mayor. Hassan is like Xi Jin Ping and Myron is like
Hinrich Himmler. I don't know if that's a good comparison, but
okay. Okay. Anyway, Myin is an unhinged racist, but he was a
fed and actually believes in many of the institutions of the
US.
This isn't talking about who's safer for
Yeah, Myron would absolutely trust in the US military's ability
to kill every
I don't know if he'd all of them because certainly they'd be
expropriating some property though. Okay.
But also, why do people think that fascists don't expropriate
property? Like that hasn't been a thing that they've done the
entire time fascism has been a thing or any authoritarian regime.
That's like literally the things author the thing authoritarians
do is expropriate people from their property, right? Expropriate.
Yeah. Property. Yeah. They take it. They dispossess people of
their property. They steal it for themselves. And they don't
they don't commod they don't commoditize it and co-op uh and
share it, right? They just steal it. What's the one quote from
Kanye about forcing himself to hate? I got no idea what you're
talking about off the top of my head. Anyway,
crazy. That's
bro, what what are we doing here? >> Uh the the well-being
of Americans, right? Free healthcare, free >> Destiny.
Correct. As usual, fik006.
Join the Discord. discord.gg/js.
Hop in the voice channels, okay? Waiting room. If you're there,
we're going to go ahead and uh get you banned. It's a Discord
or ban moment for you here.
We'll see you in just a little bit. Okay,
you're going to hop on and defend the opinion that Hassan is
a bigger threat to people than my gains. >> Free college
education. These are not like crazy concepts. These are uh things
that exist in in other comparable OECD nations, right?
So, I don't think that it's um I don't think it's necessarily
like a conspiracy theory. I think it's just like it's just a
false presentation and like a like a very uh
uh a a not necessarily successful, but like successful in certain
communities, a a smear operation that has gone on for what, five,
six, seven years at this point. It is what it is. Um, but now
that I'm seeing like the damn crack on that side without any
intervention from my end whatsoever,
that's the reason why I wanted to highlight it because I find
it to be uh interesting that people that
uh people that otherwise would never uh find a charitable interpretation
on their own are basically seeing this uh reality. They're coming
to this conclusion on their own.
Find interest in a neol center-right community. It's not a conspiracy.
These people who are observing their aligned political perspective
losing all the power and influence it had maintained a strangle
hold since the birth of third-wave politics which has demonstrated
to every voter in the west that it is a failed method of political
maintenance. Yes. Anyway, and for everything she says about how
important it is to weed out leftists like Assam because they
don't advocate enough for voting for the right candidate, she
actually doesn't even care who they vote for and tells voters
they shouldn't be voting for people if they don't think they
actually care about them. The last clip is to say if she doesn't
care who young men vote for and she doesn't think you should
vote for someone if you personally believe they don't care about
you, then it is odd because Assan and his audience would probably
fall under the category of people whom she says she doesn't actually
care about how they vote. Yet, she is constantly criticizing
them for it. The reason she gives they didn't earn anyone's vote
is probably something Hassan also believes and might even be
further than what he uh what he says. Yes, I believe that the
foundational principle of representative democracy is that our
representatives are supposed to represent our interests and and
democratic elections are supposed to be a pressure valve for
all of the anxieties that people experience, all of the anger
and resentment that people experience on a day-to-day basis.
We have a lot of issues. Our politicians are supposed to at least
advocate to solve those issues. when they don't do that and their
expectation is like shut the up and vote because the other side
is far worse. >> Okay, I'm I'm good with Assan. That's
like the whole thing with Assan. He reads a little more of the
thread. I don't know if there's anything else like amazing there.
I guess he could read >> you final thoughts. This is the
only log or clip I could find of Assan advocating for reeducation
camps. Off-hand statements does not mean policy and it seems
to >> Okay. Yeah, I'm good with this. I'm good with Assan.
We're all done. Okay. Where are we going next? Where do we go
to next? Okay.
Oh man, there's the Darius stuff is good. The Darius stuff is
good. The Willyax stuff is good. Oh no. Okay. Okay. Real quick,
we'll just go we'll go through it. Okay. Where do I got my album
here? Right here. Okay. I'll just cover the Willy Mack stuff
super quickly.
All right. So, the Willie Mac stuff. Uh, basically Willie Mack
was gone for a couple days. He goes back, tweets a 5day old tweet,
quote tweets a 5day old tweet with Destiny like attempting to
dox me like posting personal private information about me. Quote
tweets it where it's directly linked and goes, "The state of
YouTube drama is cooked.
Doxing is just above board now. Everyone has their own little
justification for it, but it's also not illegal." So genuinely
just a cooked and up rabbit hole. We've spiraled down. I totally
disavow doxing. I've never doxed anybody. I don't amplify people's
doxes. That's not something I'm interested in doing. That's not
something I want to do. It seems really stupid to to get into
that. Willie is uh apparently came back after 5 days, quote tweeted
Desi directly attempting to dox me and then pretended like gave
gave this as like a oh I guess we just dox people now, right?
I guess we just dox people now, huh? Right? It's like guys, everyone
has their own justification. No, the only purp only person who
doxes in this situation is Destiny. That is the only person.
It's not We're all We're all down this up rabbit hole. That's
not happening. That's just total sweeping for Destiny, right?
Like I don't know why you would come back after 5 days
and just totally try to like make a tweet defending Destiny essentially
going, "Oh, what Destiny does is what everybody does, and I guess
it's just not really that bad because everybody does it." Nope.
Nope. Nope.
If you remember a couple days back, maybe a week and a half ago,
Willie said that I Willie claimed that I tried to dock him, right?
What I did was I retweeted a dicker's tweet that was quote tweeting
a clipper who had clipped a Queenman's stream on the Queenman
stream in that clip. So, it was just a screenshot basically of
the clip with no information in it. If you click through to the
quote tweet in the retweet of Dickers, okay, so I retweeted Dickers,
his tweets showing on my timeline. If you click into what he's
quote tweeting, then there is a clip. Quan was looking at a Destiny
quote tweet on his stream. He let the video autoplay without
the sound on.
What he did was comment over he was making some point and the
clipper took like the speech that Queen did there and made a
clip out of it. In the background there is a censored video that
has some sensitive information about Willie Mack in it. So for
me there is no information in my tweet. If you click through,
you have to watch and then you have to be paying attention to
the background and it's like censored but poorly I think. I don't
even I don't think I watch the whole thing. I've been told it's
censored. So I I believe it's censored but it's probably shows
something, right? It probably like moves around or something.
And if you watch that that you could see that there's some like
information about Willie Mack there. So I wasn't trying to dox
him. I was disavowing doxing. I don't like doxing. Doxing is
bad, right? It's a bad thing to do. Especially if people are,
you know, if there's some reason you suspect that that docs could
be used to like harm somebody, it's not in a public interest,
right? It's especially bad to dox people when you're also calling
for those people to be, you know, that's also that's also bad.
So that's what Destiny is doing here. And he's just Willie comes
on. He's like, "Oh, shocks. It's kind of weird that this is all
just cool now." No, it's not cool. It is. I will say Willie is
getting confused here. Willie is very used to taking cues from
other people and he's taking cues from like not so erodite and
Connor and these people right and he's like oh I guess doxing
is just allowed now guys it's like no you are in a up space where
other people are allowing this and I don't know in what universe
you thought it was cool to disconnect from Dan Saltman not not
want to do a podcast and then come back and do this like what
what is going on in this brain there's like a hamster on a wheel
and it's like a fat hamster Right.
Anyway,
oh, you're Smegle. I knew I got this opinion from somewhere.
Smegle said the same thing. Willie, I don't even know why you
didn't do the podcast with Dan if doxing was your concern. You
literally did something worse than what you claim Jay's talkingers
did to you. Also, can we just get off the high horse there? Doxing
is legal. Be a normal person, Willie. Oh, Willie uh Willie does
delete this. Okay, because Auggie comes along and says, "Dude,
why are you quote tweeting people's docs? Like, are you out of
your out of your mind?
Why'd you do this?
Ah, and Smaggle makes fun of him for deleting the tweet. Reading
the Smaggle voice. The Smaggle voice. The Yanv voice. I don't
have a Y invoice. I can't do a Y invoice. Don't make me do that.
What are you guys talk? What are you guys saying? We don't do
a Y invoice here. We have no Y in voices here. Anyway,
so very
very curious, concerning behavior. just totally like
totally obliterating any reputation he had in that community
and really just driving himself further into like the like I
don't know what what is going on. Oh, is this the is this what
I retweeted? I retweeted an Aiden tweet. Wait, Aiden's very funny.
This is a good this is a good one. Maybe.
Which Aiden tweet is this? Will Max show the type of guy to quote
tweet quote retweet cam to let you know how bad he thinks it
is? I retweeted this one. This is a good one,
Oh, wait.
There's no way. Willie didn't make fun of these people over the
Mr. Beast stuff, did he? Did he also include Cher's revenge in
his sweeper video that strongly suggested she was lying about
the whole thing? I can't remember if he suggested she was lying,
but he did include like maliciously leaked, non-consensually
recorded audio in his video, and Cherry had to go to YouTube
Legal to get him to remove it. So, I believe he was contacted
by YouTube Legal and then removed it voluntarily before they
stepped in and forced it to be removed. But like it was the the
complaint had to be filed. It's crazy, right? Hey, could you
please remove that like non-consensually recorded audio from
your video? The the stuff I'm like filed a police report over.
Uh,
you know, report me if you don't like it. Good one. Good one,
Willie. Good one. Loser. Anyway, is that I don't even know if
I have an extra tweet here. I just I just thought it was crazy
that like this Willie this Willie M guy is just a goof. I'm like
I don't know. It's I I feel like I should probably be more upset,
but it's like I don't know. He's just he's like totally destroying
himself. Like the punishment is the lack the loss the total loss
of respect of any one of his peers, right? Like probably there
are some sickopants around him like in that uh in like their
group chats. There probably some sick offense who like would
maybe defend him lightly or would go like, "Oh no, I still ride
with but like they'd be total sick of they'd be total losers,
right? Every single person with anything to lose is going to
look at Willie like a leper, right? Cuz Willie tried to distance
himself from Dan. It was like doxing is really wrong. And he
goes and does this. Dude, is there a clip live thread or did
we get a thread on clipped live? You'd wonder if there's a thread
on clip live or not. You'd be shocked if there wasn't.
Lm fao. This can't be real.
Hold on. So, this is the This is like the Nick Dioro Willy Mack
Auggie.
Uh X8 Connor and Tommy Cub. Okay.
This can't be real.
Willie can't help but make an optics nightmare out of something
that gets universal sympathy. Impressive. Truly. So somehow Willie
did Yeah, Willie did get like Willy had some stuff leaked about
him by that Gatfumodor person and other people, right? And Willie
Willie like actually made it himself totally unsympathetic.
Is it really hard for Willie to just stop interacting with Destiny?
Is it really that hard for True? Oh my god. Whatever. 2774.
Is it really that hard for Willie to just stop interacting with
Destiny? Is it really that much of a problem? Like just don't
go look to quote tweet this guy. But by the way, 5 days later,
right? Like it is a 5day old tweet. So he had to go. He had his
wedding, right? His wedding was why he was off of the internet.
He came back from his wedding and went the first thing I'm doing
quote tweeting some docs. That's what I'm going to try to do.
That's what I'm going to do today. You can't make it up.
You can't make this up. Can we just say it's obvious Willie was
fine with doxing. He was fine with salvad doxing. He was fine
with destiny doxing. He was happy to passively aggressively boost
Jox dox until he got doxed. Then it was bad news.
When was he fine with salvo? Okay. Yeah, I don't know about that.
H. This is funny. People are arguing. Oh, this is actually a
fails on this one. the the publicly accessible website cope is
so funny from people. Uh Willie is perpetually over this. Okay.
D's nuts. Okay. Okay. Yeah, they they literally can't show their
face on their own subredd.
I think it's fairly ins. Like if Nick covers it, he'll he'll
do it's bad. What do you want me to say? Right.
Like it's bad. What do you want me to say? That'll be all it
is. if if he covers it at all. And I like I mean whatever. It's
his friend. I don't know. I He probably should, but
what can you do? I remember when Nick was all like, "We have
to totally police our own and we have to make sure that like
if somebody does something bad in the commentary community, we
actually call that out." I'm not sure where that Nick went. Hopefully
he comes back one day, we will accept him with open arms. He
would be very welcome. Okay, I think that's it for the Willie
stuff. I I don't think there's anything else for the Willy Mack
stuff. It was just very funny that he comes back and just like
immediately he was like, you know, the way I spurned out before
that didn't that didn't torch my reputation enough. Here's some
more gas on that fire. Did you guys forget that you were all
mad at me? Did you guys forget that I'm a total
Oh, let me throw some gas on this fire for us. Let's go. Let's
go. Okay. All right.
All right. I think we have to go. I might have to go to the Destiny
stream and the Discord stuff again. I don't even know if this
is all he did. There's probably gonna be lots of funny stuff
from Destiny's stream today, but he did actually go through a
bunch of the Discord stuff. We'll do the Darius stuff right after
this. Okay, I promise we'll get to the Darius stuff right after
this. But Destiny decided he was going to uh look over more albums
of Discord messages today from my Discord. And I'm very I'm very
interested in what he pulls up. So, let's let's take a look.
Let's take a look. He's watching Pisco. This looks like the Pisco
Avi conversation.
That's interesting. He he pauses to go check out.
Quick quick JStock Discord update, guys. Quick update. >> Also,
I just love my just major big shout out to all my wonderful fans
in the um my wonderful fans in the uh just Discord server. I
love you all very much. Again, I love how
I just love how transparent all this is. I will call this out
so I don't seem as crazy when I bring it up. I will call this
out so I don't seem as crazy when I bring it up. >> I would
have swiped right. Pisco has great eyebrows. >> Sencha.
Sencha. Uhoh. Sencha. Uh-oh.
>> Oh, cute. There. I guess it's just a nice um
It's just a nice uh Pisco fan. I
>> this one I saw this one had to be
>> She says
who's like a totally normal and chill person. But by the way,
I will say the time stamps on this, we're not exactly going back
days, are we? Why is he Why is he pretending information from
now would make his previous allegations make sense, right? So,
he's going to find stuff moving forward that gets moderated
and pretend that that justifies old
Okay, interesting. >> Destiny, don't check the mail tomorrow.
Oh, okay. Uh, I have watched I've watched this one, so I'm like,
"Oh, that seems bad. Don't do that." >> That's kind of
I guess it's such a joke though, right? >> No, I don't
think so. >> I said, "Destiny shouldn't check the mailbox
tomorrow because there may or may not be an incendiary device
in there." Like,
>> totally is about that. And by the way, this gets moderated
automatically. Now, I think today moderation was slow because
we have two mods on vacation right now. Two mods on vacation.
This this hours of the discord is not uh covered. Well, we added
some mods. Okay. Shouldn't be a problem going forward. This should
be moderated because obviously we like following the Discord
to people break the Discord to we need to uh mod that out, right?
But I think this was today,
I think. So, I don't I don't actually know. So, mods were uh
mods are on vac Yeah, mods. No, they go on vacation in their
real lives. It's not It's not on vacation from Discord, but they're
still working. It's literally on vacation in general.
>> Oh, okay. Well, cute.
>> I don't think they'll actually send, but I'm just saying
if that showed up in my Discord server, Queman and all these
other commentary, bro, loser. >> I literally have me showing
your community threatening to me and me having to go to cyber
vegan to make it up uh to get it taken down. Your community maliciously
lying about me with the juicealker stuff. And I go to like other
people in your Discord. I have all of these DMs. Why are we pretending
that this doesn't happen in your community? happens all the time.
Like I would just say this is the claim. Destiny, yes or no?
Cybervegan got harassed for months for moderating like totally
deranged hatred towards me. Like literally like death threats
and he got harassed for it. Yes or no?
Absolutely he did. >> Who are too scared to fight with
Kiwi Farms and people would all be crying about it. But uh Nicholas
Fat Oreo and all these people who are so unhinged about anything
related to my community. Dude, people in his community, there's
no way he wouldn't have like cleared the logs. Hold on.
Like, there's no way if we just Hold on.
Like, by the way, I think this is a joke just like Sencha's one
was a joke. It should it has to be moderated on Discord cuz it's
cos, right? But like, I'm going to kill Jtock L W in World of
Warcraft class. Like, there would be there'd be a bunch of things
like this. Somebody get me the Mr. mutin clip of how many times
he's been threatened with death by Destiny's community.
Why are we even Why are we pretending that this as long the the
line is it's very clear here, right? The line is if people break
the toss, if people are are crazy, if they're like threatening
violence or something or if they're doing something like doxing,
you report that to me, I I mod it immediately. We mod that it's
against the rules anyway. This would be against the rules, right?
The censa thing about the incendiary device, that's against the
rules. As soon as it's reported, that gets moderated.
It's so easy.
But, you know, it's not that that appears to not just be like
this good and it's possible this already. >> There's usually
something there that's ulterior. It's not just they're like genuinely
concerned, although a lot of people will say they are the ones
who do it. I'm just genuinely concerned with >> the Democrats
being able to win elections and being want them to get better.
I want them to reform. You know, I've seen it all the time analogously
with Israel. Like, you know, I'm just the I'm just the progressive
Zionist who wants Israel to get better and reform and then like
down the line they're like, "Oh, sorry. Yeah, I went." >> Yeah.
But you can acknowledge that there could be someone who's like
the biggest Israel supporter could be genuine in their support
for Israel and be like this is madness blah blah you know. >> Yeah.
No no of course I'm not disputing that. What I'm saying is there
is a >> they have gone full
hinged and before I get a letter dropped on my doorstep. So
>> oh he goes over the far want to go down this rabbit
hole. Did you guys see the uh the guy who posted about that in
on the Twitter community a couple days ago? I'm not going to
be able to find it. >> Uh you can pull that up. I can't
believe they're gonna try to pull the Odashara thing as a real
thing. Somebody claimed um I used to hear about this stuff more
often, but now mostly all of it has been um like weeded out.
Um because like you can't if you're part of these communities,
you generally
Oh. Oh man, I hate to I hate to do this to Zoom, former friend
of mine, but he's kind of being unhinged. Shouldn't even take
my word for how Kiwi Farms operates. Just let Zoe explain it
to you. It's crazy how scared she was of KF and how much she
hated Jtock. She even realizes the game here, though. See, they're
trying to dox me for the loose relation to you. But now that
she on me, she knows she's safe. Uh at Destiny, I'll make sure
she isn't safe. Zoe, watch your back.
Mike, well, that's just that's what the KF goal is, just to play
the game. Blah blah blah blah blah. Leave your doors unlocked,
Zoe. Locked in and some picture like like why are we pretending
we can't couldn't go back and forth on this? Like like wouldn't
slip through the cracks or Here's the thing. When it gets when
it gets posted, it should be moderated, right? I brought this
to Destiny's attention. Now obviously he will moderate it, right?
He wouldn't want people to act like this, right? That's the line.
That's where the line is. I can't You can't expect to know like
every single thing or the influencer who runs a community to
be responsible for every single action of every single community
member, right? You just moderate it. The image.
Oh god. What is the image? I Hold on. Let me pull this up off
screen real quick.
What is it? What is it? What is
Oh my goodness. It's uh
it's our buddy. It's Terry.
I'm King Terry the Terrible. Zoe will be executed with an A10
rifle. The fist of God.
Oh, that's not unhinged. That's totally normal. That's totally
not more directed. Oh, yeah. We're totally Guys, this is totally
meaningful. This is totally meaningful. We should totally do
this. Yeah. Very cool. Very super cool. All right. Anyway. All
right. He's going to pull. >> You have to hate You have
to hate me. It's like part of the rule, I guess. Uh Destiny alleges
that just Queen alongside Kiwi Farms are behind the Dodite Josiah
and Hutch and they were
>> He pulls he pulls up my showing the logs of him saying
I'm 98% sure that person isn't from your community. Right. >> Just
to be clear, I don't do this themselves. I think that they're
they just like give a lot of cover to and then a lot of information
inflow um or a lot of
>> they give a lot of cover to and a lot of information
inflow. You're doxing people for information inflow. when you
literally when you talked about information inflow the first
time you then 10 minutes later said guys who send me stuff from
Kiwi Farms can you DM me this there's no >> information
flow between these communities I don't think they themselves
do it I don't even know if they themselves or their communities
do it I think it's generally it happens on KF and then they just
amplify it and then give cover to it
>> what does give cover to it mean he's not making any
actual accusation they just amplify and give cover to it so here's
here's even another challenge amplify show us amplif lifing.
What do you think amplifying is? Is amplifying taking a clip
of something from Kiwi Farms that's archived on Kiwi Farms and
viewing a clip with information that we would just go to without
a watermark anyway. Is that what amplifying is? That can't possibly
be the standard for amplifying.
That can't possibly be the standard for being held responsible
for the that goes on on Kiwi Farms, right? It's insane. Oh, the
concern trolling is so gay. It's always It's always It's okay
when we do it if it's just haha funny, but then when the out
group does it, it's serious and should be reported. Yeah. Like
I'm just I'm trying to hold us both to the same standard, right?
Like, hey, this has been reported now. Obviously, this happens
in both places. Why are we pretending it's not like equivalent?
The line is if it's reported and it breaks your your either something
against your rules or it's against the toss of the platform,
you moderate it. If you just want to say that DGG chat is a pro-
doxing space where you allow people to post docks and you allow
people to uh to do like whatever the make threats of violence
that's your what you that's fine. Wait, so he's walking back
that we're an unhinged doxing community. Apparently entirely
Porter Beller. Yes. Apparently he is entirely walking that back.
Although he wants to amplify the Odishara thing now, so hard
to say. But this guy said, "So, I wasn't in belief of this at
first, but after confronting just about it, I was pretty sure
uh it was from that community. A couple months ago, I'm a fan
of Destiny in the Jurgisal server. Someone in his community sent
a letter to my home. I've moved since then to my house saying
I quote, "Defend Destiny because I want to my wife and my patients."
To be fair, I was pretty active in his community for a bit, even
after the Py stuff happened. To say it was just a random attack
wouldn't be totally fair. Um,
>> is he going to go over anything? >> I've got DMs
from people who say that like if they see you active in both
communities that people will get unhinged or do like crazy unhinged.
>> people can we get an actual accusation?
People have DM'd me to say that when you communicate in both
communities, people get unhinged and do crazy unhinged.
Can we get an just do an actual actually just say what they said?
Why would you not just say what they said? It's so embarrassing.
Just nothing, right? Absolutely nothing. Uh, I'm not going to
bring up chats talking about people who are in both communities.
It's wild that Dan sent that letter. Dude, Dan, by the way, Odashara
did complain about Dan doxing him. Dan did dox him. Yes, Odashara,
tell everybody about Dan doxing you and how you cried about it
in the VCs.
Please, please go ahead. Any word from Connor on a discussion
about the debate and his tweets? Uh, I don't think I asked Connor
for a debate. I could ask him. We'll see if he wants to come
on and talk about it. His his point was you should ask Destiny
for his evidence. It's like, brother, I am asking Destiny for
his evidence anywhere. So, Destiny, just to be clear here, what
Destiny has proven is one per uh sorry, at least one person has
I guess said that he might be receiving a bomb in the mail, which
is wrong and that was that was moderated.
I guess well, we'll see cuz I apparently I've got two timestamps
here. We'll see what else happens. But he has not proven doxing.
He's not proven any of the actual allegations that like Quimman
or ori should be held responsible for what KF does, which is
the entire problem, right? Not a date and Destiny are saying
that Quimman and Jtock condone and make make possible doxing
and swatting. We still have seen zero evidence of that, but they're
going to try to connect these communities somehow. Right? This
is what they do. They basically can't actually from the claims
they make, they have no no point they can make, right? They can't
prove any of their claims. And so they will try to subtly walk
back the claims with the evidence they show. They'll go, "Look,
this proves that they're unhinged." But was that the allegation
just that we were unhinged? Or was it that just that we don't
like you?
You can't you can't dox people and harass them for not liking
you. That's not where the line is. You can't you can't dox people
for not liking you, right?
He said, "They help me get doxed. They they're they contribute
to the community that gets me spotted. They they're a part of
this group. They let it happen. They're they're playing cute.
They're playing footsies with with Kiwi Farms. It's like, "Okay,
show us where your evidence is of this. Show us any evidence
you have. Not evidence you're collecting today or yesterday or
tomorrow. The evidence you had when you started trying to dox
us. Show us that evidence." Uh, how are we supposed to be certain
these crazies aren't coming from DG in the first place? Many
of them are. Um, who I had another What's this person's name?
I don't remember what it was. I want to read this person's message
entirely. Um,
so all authors get a little bit. My problem is I don't have an
off-ramp for hanging out with people. I like being a DGG. Uh
but anytime you do this, uh they'll keep bringing up chatters
in DG non-stop talking about their personal lives and even sending
letters to one's house because they defended you. I think this
guy's referring to the guy here on the Twitter thread. I feel
like if I I would want any evidence of this allegation. So if
you don't know who Odashar is, Odosar is an incredibly embarrassing
loser who's banned multiple times for homophobic slurs in the
Discord. He's an incredibly embarrassing loser who constantly
talks about being uh talks about his job. I don't know if he
says it in his Twitter profile anymore. Um
he's like he's just very embarrassing. He's very like dumb. He
gets into arguments with people. He gets very high and gets into
arguments with people in the VC, right? And then he gets made
fun of and he gets very upset about it and he'll say like a homophobic
slur and get banned and he'll pop back in. I openly said he didn't
have any evidence. Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, he didn't have any
evidence. He doesn't have any evidence, right? So, he's just
like he's like a total loser. And he basically he came to me
one day a couple months ago and said, "Hey, I got sent a letter
from somebody who said that they were a member of the Jtock community
and I defend Destiny because I want to my patients and my wife."
And it's like, "Okay." I I tried to humor him a little bit, right?
I was like, "Okay, uh, sure. Can I just see the letter? Can you
send me the the letter?" And he was like, I threw it out
And it's like
Bro, what? So, you you've been getting like razed for being a
loser in the Discord and now somebody dropped a letter off at
your house apparently
that apparently you have somebody who's willing to come after
you, right?
At your house was willing to look you up and they say they include
in this letter, I'm from the Jaw community
apparently,
right? And your first
upon learning this is to immediately throw the letter out.
Not only that,
to wait several days so that when I'm like, "Oh, could you like
get it out of the trash?" That you're like, "No, no, no. It was
like it was days ago. It's gone." I don't know how to
like, can we
can we be serious? I'm pretty sure the DMs end with me literally
like mocking him for being like it's like dude you you're claiming
you have like somebody who's come to your house and dropped something
off, right? Or they've sent it through the mail to your house.
They know where you are. They've looked you up and they're crazy
enough to send stuff to your house and you just threw this out.
You didn't call the cops. You didn't like create a record of
this. You were like, "No, I just don't Yeah, I don't need any
proof of this." Like I And that's apparently the level we're
at, right?
That's the level we're at with with the DJers right now.
Only a DJ would project that level of fervor for a community
onto another community. You couldn't get me to admit I'm part
of the Jaw community at gunpoint. Okay. Time out, evil Johnny
Bravo. Take his perms. Time him out. Get him out of here. Get
him out. Get him out of here. Okay. All right. Hang on to DG
and stop typing in there. I'll have stalkers on me, too, just
because of how they slowly go crazy about people when they are
gone. It feels like there's some other sane people like me in
there, but it's just scary to be honest. And the fun place to
type in while dinking around at work uh turned into a kiwi farms
around us slowly. Uh maybe you feel like I deserve it. Oh, this
guy thinks I hate him. I don't I was like, but that's like one
of like three people, right? I would just I would love to know
who these people are because there are some people who basically
like are complete losers,
right? And they they want to be back in DG. They want to be back
in DG's Good Graces.
There's like a handful, right? That's like one of two or three
people almost certainly
very sad individuals, very wretched individuals. Yeah, I think
a lot of people are in both places and don't think there's anything
to do with Kiwi Farms in my Discord, right? Like there's just
no no part of that. Who? No, I'm not going to do that right now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There's a lot of like crazy There's just
so much unhinged crazy. Sorry. There's just so much unhinged
crazy, but we're not posting any evidence. We keep posting At
least I'll give this to Odashara. At least Odashara makes his
direct allegation so we can laugh at him for the he is. Destiny
won't even make an allegation, right? Destiny will just go, "It's
just crazy unhinged. It's just crazy and unhinged, guys. It's
just so crazy and unh It's just unhinged and crazy,
right? That he won't even make a direct allegation." I haven't
talked about this for like the past few months because I like
try to do like don't give cover to or don't um like they don't
say anything about it. It's not real. But um yeah, Jesus Christ.
Didn't Jessica want to make a dock to send everyone send to everyone
that interacts with Destiny? Yes, they were talking about that
on KB farms because they were going to help him on KB farms make
it. Um they were posting a lot of >> I said that would
be like a good idea. Uh I was too lazy to follow through on it.
I already stream enough, but I did say that would be a good idea
>> about doing the Reddit for that times. >> Unfortunately,
I'm just not like a latigious or report happy person by nature.
I just kind of like let it go.
A >> certain pattern that's indicative of the former rather
than the latter. one pattern that I've
so there's literally
there's literally no solid allegation against the Discord except
that that log from Sencha that she was moderated for.
Interesting.
Very interesting. Okay, I got one more time stamp. Apparently,
he pulls up more logs on the Discord. Let me take a look. Let
me take a look. Let me take a look. Oh, hold on. I should uh
>> Wait before he goes back to this. How long? 305.
I should just skip forward a little bit to make sure he's like
actually just doing pisco. Oh no, he he doesn't just do pisco.
>> Hold on. Apparently my Oh, apparently they're trying
to do this to my uh Twitter space mod guy now. Um Icarus. He
just sent me this. >> I don't think I've seen dumber, more
subservient person in this space than Icarus. It's like two to
three people who never liked Icarus beforehand and then some
like like some others who are just disappointed that he spreads
the Destiny lie propaganda.
I'm not going to lie, I still don't even really know who Iris
is. He's like a Twitter Destiny mod or something, right? seems
so low on the totem pole, bro. Icar Icarus is here. All right,
spit it out. Icarus, what is Yeah, Icarus is just amplifying
like totally baseless lies and like happy to do it, right? He's
obviously just a total loser who has no internal monologue or
like personal sense of morality. I kind of thought I thought
that wasn't the case. He used to come to like all the older calls
and stuff and used to try to hop on stream. I kind of figured
like, oh, this guy's like normal. He won't uh he won't totally
support like a doxing loser. But actually he does like completely
fullthroatedly. He loves doxing. He loves being in a doxing community.
And yeah, just any accusation these people could put on me, I
can actually put on them, right? Like it is a doxing community.
Destiny's community is a doxing community
100%. Anyway, but I don't I don't know where the unhinged thing
is here. That wouldn't be a thousand times worse in actual DG
chat. >> Icarus and are docking buddies, man. It's I feel
this is for spit of Icarus when he was going through his homeless
era. All right, spit out Icorus. Bro, Icarus is here. Not going
to lie, I s Does he think if he reads it in like the malicious
voice, this sounds crazy?
Uh, no. We don't have to lie about these people. It's fine. We're
going to be the reliable people and it will work in the end,
you know. Do these people deserve the the like not to have the
tactics used against them? Probably not, but we just don't avow
the tactics. So, disavow the docking buddies comment. ban that
guy, dude. It's like it's all just jokes and they're the most
milktoast jokes. Like none of these jokes are even offensive.
Don't even really know who Iris is. He's like a Twitter desk
or something, right? Seems so low on the tote. Um I now, okay,
I'll be honest. I don't know if he means this here, but on Kiwi
Farms, usually people will say like, "Oh, who even is this guy?"
And that's usually an indication where somebody tried to dox
them, right? Who are they? Uh, just to be clear, Icarus, him
pulling this up is 100%. Like Kiwi Farms does not watch most
of my streams, okay?
Him pulling this up is his attempt to get them. He is giving
positive attribution to people, right? He's telling them, "Well,
it really bothers me when Kiwi Farms does this stuff. Oh, look
at them making fun of Icarus." He is very much praying to God
that Kiwi Farms doxes you so that he can make himself the victim.
I hope you know that, right? That is actually his goal right
now is he wants to put a big target on your back. Look at this
guy's this guy's doing this. They don't follow me on Twitter.
They're not like they're not here following me my every word
on Twitter or something, right? This is this is what they want
100. This is what Destiny wants. It's why he constantly interacts
with Kiwi Farms, right? It's why he's constantly had to do it
his entire career. He loves this stuff. Who is this person? I
don't know if that's what this guy means here cuz I again they
don't usually do the doxing in uh just Discord server. I don't
think I've seen that before. So he might just be asking what
I >> Oh, so he admits there's no doxing that happens in
my server. So he said it was a doxing Kiwi farmer community,
right? And he has no evidence of that. He's totally walked it
back. He has completely conceded on that idea. Now what justification
does he have for doxing me or anybody in my community trying
to dox anyone around us,
right? He's totally fallen back from this entirely. It's like
two three people who never liked Icarus beforehand and then like
some others who are disappointed that he spreads the Destiny
lie propaganda.
I don't think I've seen dumber, more subservient person in the
space than Icarus. These comments are all in the past like hour.
Oh, no, no,
Never mind. Apparently, yeah, I quote tweeted him, bro. There's
like five comments.
There's like five comments. Like, just think about that. I quote
tweeted this guy amplifying lies cuz he was a part of my community.
He used to join all the other calls. He used to be around all
the time, right? I quote tweeted him go, "It's kind of weird
for you to like amplify this." Cuz I messaged him. And I was
like, "It's weird for you to amplify this and allow it in your
community." And he goes, "Bro, I don't know anything. I'm just
a I'm just a I'm just a small bean. I don't know anything, guys."
Right? I don't know anything.
I've not been online. And then he retweets Odashara. And I'm
like, "This is another baseless lie that you're amplifying."
That seems kind of odd. Also, uh, Icarus posted in the Discord
as well. Yeah, Icarus is probably a part of the community. But
it's like, dude, what what what do you think you're proving here
with any of this? That like this guy who amplifies a story that's
totally baseless that me criticizing him and then he people are
like, you're you're a loser.
Is this what have we what have you
What is going I think he just wants to he wants to encourage
people to go be unhinged towards him in the discord, right? He
wants to encourage this. He's literally trying to show a pattern
of if you say bad things about me, I'll pull you up on my stream
and spur about it. Right guys, if you if you say bad things in
the Jto disc D discord, I'll pull you up on my stream and spur
about it. I
Do you see that? The thing he's trying to reinforce here, the
pattern, it's just goofy. >> Jessica was going at him.
>> He He knows he's literally giving me this exact advice.
Guys, don't actually go and look at this stuff, right? Don't
go and look at this stuff. You'll just give you'll give trolls
all all the credit in the world. You help them out. Totally.
He's told me this, right?
>> He's told this to everybody who freaks out about like
little insults, people like like insulting them in random corners,
right? Just chill. They'll move on to a different target. It'll
be fine,
but he can't take the advice himself. Okay, enough.
>> I'm a major major Republican, but my whole thing is
I'm the Republican soothsayer and I'm the one who's trying to
make a judgment specifically for the Republican party. Give example
in Israel context right there people who say for example the
reason we have to focus so much on the Israel Palestine um conflict
and the reason we have to focus spend so much time on it is because
America's involved with Israel they're not with like Sudan or
they're not with like um the people like you know what I'm talking
about like that there's some reason related to the proximity
or areas of interest or area of expertise I'll give another example
I spend most of my time talking about domestic policy as relates
like corruption I don't spend most of my time like doing um social
theory I don't spend most of my time um even on foreign policy
I don't my time on social policy most of my um my content is
focused on either hard political analysis for with an access
to legal stuff and that's just because of his main interest and
like >> Okay, hold on. Does he get into any more Discord
stuff here?
Any more Discord stuff before? No, not before this time stamp.
So, this is the next time stamp. >> This was the guy who
got banned. Um, I guess who they sent the letter to. He just
sent me all his DMs with a Listen, whatever beef your community
or I'm sorry. Listen, whatever beef with your community I have,
I don't believe it was >> Oh, these logs make me look fantastic.
I was thinking about putting these logs out. Surely he'll include
the part at the end where he says, "Guys, it's a 98% chance it's
not the JSTOK Discord, right?" Destiny wouldn't leave that log
out, right? Surely not because of you. Or from like 98% of the
people I engaged with, but I just decided I'm going to tell you
something that happened to me during my oneweek ban from Jube
a while ago. Someone sent uh someone sent me something to my
house, a letter that was Okay, hold on. Let me uh let me pull
the old rap sheet here because we're probably going to need that
if we have Sorry, I'm messaging Wick back. Give me a second.
Okay. Uh let's see here. Hit play on this.
someone from the logistical community found my actual home address.
Had a bunch of inflammatory statements and whatnot. But I just
wanted you to know that I do not believe it was from you or your
higher ups or anything like that.
>> I have also, despite what others claim, never given
enough information for my docs to be found. The only public information
is two things. I live in blank and nearby parking a walk to.
That's it. Dan literally doxed him. Dan literally doxed him.
He l How many people have been in the in the VCs where where
Dan is like he literally complained to me directly about Dan
doxing him?
>> So it's weird because he's also said guys my it's really
easy to find me or something. So I don't blame Dan that much.
Dan is denying in the Discord right now.
>> We'll see.
I guess Jess says send a picture. And then uh this guy responds,
"I tossed it immediately. It's straight up a skitso rant, calling
me a and saying I have the stance I do, so I can keep on my partner
and my patience. It was typed out and not like a handwritten
thing." Jessica says, "Okay, I'm not saying that didn't happen."
>> Time first time out on here, November 26th, 2024. Reposting
a doc good one.
>> That's the first thing he was timed out for. Literally
the first thing in his timeout sheet is reposting a docs. Good
one to read.
Okay. All right.
>> But the speed at which it happens is insane. Like you
got a full-blown corer mail from someone in that short a period
of time. Uh he says, "I mean, if it was local, I wouldn't imagine
it would take that long to send a letter within the US. It's
less than 5 days. Our USPS is fastest." I'm only telling you
this because I don't even believe it was intended to make it
seem like this is what the district community does or anything
like that. Um that would be actually crazy to endorse or encourage
or anything of that sort. But I've told a few others debating
on what I should do with it. And I decided I should come to you
to talk to you about this. The fact that there are people to
this day saying I either support and am a in waiting which is
something you said on stream a bit ago or at least I argue like
a waiting will eventually encourage this behavior. I don't know
if this thing has anything to do with arguing about my stuff
or not but okay. Um he's very big on like yeah we call DJs and
waiting because they don't understand the concept of consent.
So apparently within days of me debating talking to him on stream,
he was sent a letter calling him a been waiting because I might
have said that about him on stream. Apparently that that makes
sense. Somebody knew about him and sent like a courier mail or
something, right?
this is absolutely true. A bagel and coffee. Yes, it is very
funny that Destiny would much rather make content with my Discord
than not so erodite. Like this is far more engaged than he's
ever been on bridges. Okay, that's just true. That's just fact,
bro. That's just facts. He misses being in the Discord. So, yes,
this is the thing is like within days of that argument happening,
>> Like trying to define me. >> Oh, wait. I got banned
for. So when he was banned for seven days for somebody saying
accusing him of his fiance and his patients, he then got a letter
saying that they were his fiance and his patients. So the thing
that he got that he said he called somebody an fsler in response
to and got banned from the discord, right? Apparently a letter
magically appeared days later, right?
Days later a letter magically appeared that said the same thing.
And we believe that appar apparently apparently me as being a
um being a or whatever. Um now I have moved. My address has changed.
Uh it was a planned move. I had no fear. Um it was a planned
move. I had no fear for my life or anything like that. This rhetoric.
It just needs to chill the out. Right. It's it's just an attempt
to chill like what he doesn't like which is basically being mocked
for his horrible argue. He had no argument for why he was saying
what he was. Right. That's the whole thing. Like absolutely no
argument
And because he was being mocked for being a loser who has no
internal monologue, he goes, "This rhetoric has gone way too
far, guys. This is crazy." And by the way, I'm waiting because
you don't understand the reason I'm reaching out for seven days
right now for using a slur in voice chat. Yeah, I did it, but
in retaliation, people accusing me of my fiance and my patients.
I'll leave the 7-day ban, but I'm truly hoping some things change
by then.
>> What is this? So, probably time. This is Odara's.
What is this? So Odosara automod banned for saying the f slur
when you try to consult Odishara
when Dan doxed him and now he's a hater for some reason and on
the sex doxing sex pest side of things.
This is in a space he should interact me thing with me thanks.
Okay not going to litigate that cuz but I don't know what this
is a reference to. It's like way later this like two months later
or something.
I asked Jtock mods to try to condemn a random making an alt account
to find me to talk to me and make weird accusations. And they
tried to say, "Well, you talk about Discord. You deserve it."
Like crazy.
>> I'm glad I left the JCO server cuz holy, they are insane.
Like they fantasize about one man so much. Why can't I call them
gay? Can we call them slurs yet?
Okay. Well, he's clearly had no problem with it. dropping the
fslur in VC chat. Banned for using the fslur.
Apparently the jube 7day was also a ban for the fslur. Hold on.
Where is it? Where is it? There was a jube 7day that was an one
as well. Stand by your logs if you're going to talk. This is
the one right here. This would be the the jube fsler right here.
Crazy.
Bro, pisco subreddit needs help. DG trolling hard. Yeah, they'll
they'll brigage. It's whatever. It's whatever.
So this one, this one 100% happened. He 100% said Dan doxed him.
>> I don't know why Dan would go back against that. So
the docs there was not like like what do you call it? Address,
but it was apparently saying his name like using his name with
him or something. Yeah, apparently. Let me see here. Looking
around.
>> Oh, one second. I'm
Sorry. Sending messages, chatting with people, took the date
log. This was when he left the server, but we uh but came back
because he thought people in VC were cool. Oh, right. Sorry,
sorry, sorry. So, he said, "Oh, these people are totally insane.
These people like talk make al accounts to talk about me." And
then he comes back way later and I'm
that's what it was, right? He was talking and saying it's like
a doxing community and like talking all kinds of about us, right?
>> I see. He would like he would like go and talk about
the Discord in places, right? Say people are like trying to track
him down and and nobody liked him here
and then he came back and was like, "Guys, I just like hanging
out in the VCs actually."
So dropping the floror in chat was this one or in VC and then
I banned him because he kept talking about people. He just he
was like talking the space. I was like, "Dude, you don't have
to be here. Go away."
Got it.
Got it. All right. Yeah. Well, that's the problem as well. People
in VC did not think he was cool. Yeah. It was basically he was
just like a loser. He'd get high and he wanted like friends.
He'd just get high and sit there and be like a worthless blob
and then get really offended when people would mock him. He spent
a week plus the VCs trying to argue H-1Bs
H1B ones with Sakonos and Spinboy. Oh, good. Would love his opinion
on that. All right, where are we headed now? Oh, guys, I didn't
even notice. Guys, we need donations. Oh my god. Oh my god. We
have what is it? Uh,
need 12? We need nine subs. Nine subs to add two hours to the
stream, guys. Nine subs right now. I know you can do it. Okay,
we're going to keep going. There's so much content. You have
to keep the stream going. I need you to keep it alive. For the
love of God, help me fight off future homelessness. Okay, we
can keep looking at unhinged Discord logs all night
or whatever the Destiny's doing here. Anyway, so this is the
Odashar thing. I timed him out in
right? And he still came back. I don't know. Did he pay me? I
should go see if he paid me when I said still $50 to come back.
I should go see if he actually paid me back. That would be good
to know. I will donate if you promise to send me a letter in
the mail. Uh, if you want to send me your address, gentle whale,
I will send you a letter in the mail if you donate. >> I
will do it. Spruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's
go.
Okay, we're going to continue listening to this story.
>> Jessica right now for using a slur in voice chat. Yeah,
I did it, but in retaliation, people accusing me of my fiance
and my patients. I'll leave the 7-day ban, but I'm truly hoping
some things change by then. >> So, he got a 7-day ban for
somebody saying this to him. And then he goes, "Guys, I actually
got IRL harassed in the exact same way that I spurred doubt about
in VCs, okay, and used a slur and got banned. Uh, but somebody
made that exact same allegation directly to me through my through
my address." And also, I didn't keep the letter cuz that wasn't
really scary.
Like, this is the level of IQ this person has, right? And Destiny
has too, apparently. I mean, Destiny's clearly just maliciously
going to replplatform it as if it could be true, right?
But everybody can say that this is obviously totally moronic
to believe.
>> Uh Marad, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. We
are what? What did I say? Nine. So seven. Seven subs away. We
could do it. We could do it. >> I have no idea about any
of that. I just feel like throwing away evidence of someone who
is potentially an unhinged stalker is in and of itself unhinged.
Please give anything that comes your way going forward. >> Yeah,
I didn't want to hold on to a letter telling me that I rape my
patients or my fiance, but I appreciate you at least reading
my message. You >> Gentle whale with the 10 gifted. Let's
That's two more hours on the stream right there. 2612.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Thank you very much, gentle whale,
for coming in huge. Okay, that's uh what? 60
exactly, right? 70 exactly and 75. So, we'll add 15 to the next
timer, guys. Thank you very much. Sorry, the math is not math
tonight for me. Usually very quick with that math for the next
stream goal. Stream hours plus one 15 and boom boom boom.
Oh, come on guys. August 1st tomorrow. That's crazy.
>> Sophia donated 25.
>> I leave for a week and everything is on
>> Damn. Well, welcome back Sophia. Good to have you back.
So 25. That's uh we're $5 away. We're one sub away from another
hour on the stream again, guys. Jeez, we're just we're we're
adding them up fast. We're racking them up. Going to reset the
subs and we're good to go. All right, let's just Thank you. Jessica
says, "You understand that is insane, right?" And Odashar says,
"Fighting my real doc, sending me a letter saying I my porter
and my patient saying I only defend destiny so that I can Oh,
that's why remember if you don't take the unhinged anti-destiny
position like you
Do we believe that this happened? I'm sorry. This is how you
should deal with this person.
>> I'm sorry. This is 100% how you deal with this. This
is like absolutely
>> right? And this isn't the first time we've had this
guy like spuring out and saying it's totally unfair that people
mock him. >> It's not even close to the first time.
>> Like I feel I feel a little bad for him now that he's
like kind of put himself in the middle of this that he's like
um
kind of going to just be double humiliated. a little bad, but
it's like, yeah, I'm sorry if you have no if you have no evidence
and it's like actually um people are really unhinged and somebody
found my address and I didn't keep any evidence of this, but
also because I'm I'm like moving and like uh I'm not worried
about that guy having my name apparently or anything to that
he would have used to find my address. I'm just mostly worried
about well I can't really tell you what I'm worried about, right?
Like it's just it's just
the lowest IQ person with the lowest IQ allegation. It doesn't
make any sense. Nobody would believe this in any other context.
Uh, also guys, thank you for very much for the two gifted. There
was bub rub and it was revoke 78.90. Thank you guys very much.
Like I hate that. I I know I sound like an saying this, right?
But I think this is like actually this is the correct take. Like
I I literally don't care.
I'm sorry if you could give me no evidence. If your if your broad
understanding of this is you talking about my lack of understanding
of consent as me making me a wedding means other people are going
to harass me at my house. That's not what that means. That's
goofy as right. He's unironically that weird kid in school that
tells you about their uncle being a Navy Seal with 200 and he
taught him a secret pressure point or something. Yeah. It's just
like random little lies to make himself seem special. That's
>> You will be you will be destroyed in these servers.
Yeah. Okay. So, that's
>> uh literally no person who's good at arguing these things,
who can who can argue these things at all has any trouble in
these servers, right? Like literally all you have to do is be
like polite and there's no problem.
There are people in my server with the DGG server tag. There's
actually I think we have like four Destiny Discord mods who just
hang out in my server and in the VCs. Like there's a why why
don't those people get unhinged harassment? Do you think people
don't know that? Like uh do you think people don't know that
you're you're mods?
There's tons of people from Destiny VCs who hang out in my Discord.
I have no problems at all. You can also just like not argue it.
Yeah. It's like dude, the only people who had any issue were
the people who would constantly embarrass themselves like Yog,
right? Those are the only people who have any issue at all.
Nobody else had any problems.
That's why they're going after him. Okay, makes sense. Um, also
remember Odo Sher. This guy's first message is like, I'm not
saying it's from your community. I don't think anybody in your
community did it or none of the high-erups. I don't think you
guys endorse that. Like he was even trying to be careful on this,
but you have to carry the community line. Um, >> no. This
uh this is us being like pretty done with this guy being a to
like a turbos everywhere. He's like the community, right? This
is like um who could I think of there'd be like Destiny community,
right? Like that you just know they're lying. Like if
I'd almost say Darius, like if Darius came to you and said, "I
got a letter, but I threw it out and it says like you can't make
fun of me for tattooing redact on me anymore, guys. Guys, you
can't do that, right?" It's like I got made fun of for my tattoos,
so you can't make fun of my tattoos anymore.
Like, okay, okay, buddy. Okay, dude. >> Saying only defend
Destin and then claim it's from your community. Like, why mention
your at all? Even if they're a super big fan doing this, why
throw your name in it? Just says, I'm telling you that not taking
a picture and throwing it out is probably something only a completely
insane person would do. He says, "Why would I want to keep that
anywhere?" Just says, "Because it would be from a completely
unhinged schizophrenic that you should probably start a record
of for your own safety." Does Destiny disagree with that? Wait,
who disagrees with that?
Who disagrees with that point? Oh, sorry, dude. Dude,
it's 100% sus as this is a fake story.
Yeah, sorry. Even Even the people in his chat can see that it's
obviously
a fake story.
He's going to say say or imply you're victim blaming. I am victim
blaming, but I know this person. They're like a total [__]
>> He says, "I've moved. People who do this stuff online
are mostly cowards. If they were sure they were sending it to
my home and wanted to hurt me, uh, then they have either showed
up by now or contacted others around me, like my my fiance. I'm
way more scared of the violence I see at my job as a nurse than
some skitso online." Um, I can sort of see point here, like why
wouldn't you say that? But I've actually tossed letters like
this before, but although I'm more of a long figure, it's like
they'll send it from like not PO box addresses, but from like
a post office. You have no idea. But you don't you don't toss
it. If you're concerned about it, right? That's the whole thing.
If you're concerned about it, if you want to do something about
it, then you don't toss it. If you just go, "Oh, that's" and
you throw it away, right? Cuz you've been like doxed or something
online, let's say. That's understandable. That's totally understandable.
Toss the only evidence you have. >> Find it. And usually
people are that unhinged, they're going to they're not going to
be have to like mail it from their home, you know. Jessica says,
says, "Like, as much as you hopefully were joking about our healthcare
being in danger because I'm a nurse, I'm at a much higher risk
of a patient tracking me down, especially the actual psych patients
and unhinged family I deal with. Threaten me to my face. They
know where I work, what I look like, and my first and last name,
which is incredibly unique. But to reiterate, I'm like 98% positive
that this wasn't someone from your community. I just wanted to
bring it to your attention." So, I'm I'm pretty sure that like
you don't have to do any but you know, you should probably not
say that I'm been waiting when I argue that these people clearly
consented because they had had any relationship with Destiny.
I should be able to argue that any relationship is permanent
consent. And if you imply I'm a waiting or that I don't understand
consent, then you're actually endorsing harassment against me
IRL
is what I'm being told, right? But also, I'm 98% sure it wasn't
from your community and like I don't want you to like pretend
that I want anything here. Does he want you to do about it? I
have no idea. Well, sorry. What he wants me to do is moderate
my language towards destiny.
That's what he wants me to do, right?
He's he he implies in one of the previous logs like calling me
a led to this. That is what he's implying, right? He says the
exact language you use or something is what was used against
me. It's what got used in the VC and that got put in a letter
to my house. Now, did he send all of these logs or did he send
because
listen, I don't know how much I don't know how much
detail I want to go into, but uh people from the server reached
out and were way softer and tried to help him
find out who this was. The only person they found is somebody
who's only in the DG Discord and has DGG for life in their in
their bio. That's the only person they found that like Odosara
thought was like somebody involved as far as I can tell. So I
don't think they I don't think Odoshara even believes that this
is somebody from my community spill. Well, I don't want to I
I haven't asked the person if I could leak DMs. So I will have
to ask if I could leak further DMs or get further context, but
like people tried to be softer than I was cuz I was just like
I was done with this guy's like a complete [__] like
all over the place, right? This is the original energy vampire.
I was totally done with him and other people tried. Other people
like, "Oh, I feel bad for you and I'll talk to you about." And
he was like, "Yeah, he had he had no
Like he he I think he genuinely believes he's being like gangstaled
online.
>> The only reason he believes is someone from this community
is because Destiny says this place doxes people and is unhinged.
Okay. I think he said it was I I don't know if that's true or
sorry I don't know what it I think what he was doing when he
messaged me was clearly you should consider like reconsider being
like nicer to Destiny cuz it's going to make me it's going to
make me get hurt. Who are these nice people in the Discord? Oh,
there are nice people in the discord anemone. They're there mostly
the VC community
mostly. Mostly
all right from there where are we going?
Um, you got anything more on this? >> And then after that,
um, this was March 9th, 2025 at 1:54 p.m. 3 hours later, he is
permanently banned from just >> 10 days later, he was permanently
banned from the server.
March 9th to March 19th, there's no way he
>> keeps doing that, right? >> Days king, an actual
king. Yeah. >> 10 days later. This guy like totally incapable
of reading time stamps or Wait, did he >> Oh, and then
I still >> Wait, I said for your own safety because he's
like clearly a who is constantly like all over >> this
particular guy to this day. Go hard. It's crazy. Destiny is sending
known patient odosara very concerning
>> I'm sorry. There's no way that Destiny could possibly
complain about this after after the he lets his community say
about all of his friends, right? This is clearly somebody going,
"Oh, this bothers this guy. I'm going to I'm going to meme in
that direction." Right? Sorry.
That's that is unhinged, but that's not something I'm going to
moderate against.
there was a person I used to engage with a long time ago on social
media. Um, I'm not going to say anything in particular about
this, but maybe I'll do screenshots in the future of this cuz
I don't want to give away. Wait, what did he change his name
to?
>> Not Weed Lau. >> Very concerning. >> By
the way, Weed Lauo, longtime member of the DG Discord and the
DG fitness channel. Just saying.
there was a person I used to engage with a long time ago on social
media. Um, I'm not going to say anything in particular about
this, but maybe I'll
>> screen back and correct the time stamp. I guess who
this is, but like um there's a person I used to interact with
a long time ago on social media who has been stalked and harassed
in real life because somebody was convinced I don't know if they
were a farmer or somebody from server. Somebody was convinced
that I sent this person a ton of videos of me and Pixie or me
and other people and they found this girl's address and started
contacting her work with AI Photoshop nudes of her and me, even
though I've never met this person in real life. Um claiming that
they were going to try to get them fired from every job that
they're at. Did >> he just Did he just ponder if that came
from my community with no evidence at all? Cool.
>> Very cool. >> And then harass them and their family
members until they admit and then send them the stuff that I
supposedly sent her about uh Pixie any other person. I've never
seen this person anything like this before, right? But just this
is like the level of like insane unhinged. I would show screenshots
of this, but I don't want to give. So, he just, by the way, he
just went and showed like the previous thing and then he like
he follows up with and also the I don't know if this came from
this server, but here's another thing that
for obvious reasons. Um, but yeah, this everything around this
is like these people are insane.
>> Oh [__] I'm not even like Okay, >> I
think regardless
>> all of all of the insane people are in Look, the insane
they're everywhere, guys. These people are everywhere shaping
chats, shaping minds,
waving their Israeli flags all over the place. >> Apparently,
the span date was a couple weeks later. Um, I thought it was
the same day, but it's not the same day. My bad. It wasn't 309.
It was 319. My bad. So, it was 10 days later. But >> the
meme here is him saying, "Oh, I everybody here is really unhinged."
And he came back and was like, "No, I want to be here. No, I
want to talk to people in the VCs." And I'm like, "Bro, if it's
like so dangerous here, leave, right? If you're gonna go complain
about me in a community with somebody trying to like dox me and
yeah, you yourself in a video game, you loser. Okay, get out
of my
>> Don't go don't go try to talk about me in another community
and then go actually I want to come back and be in the VCs here.
No
>> notion of pinky. >> whatever your notion should
be is thank you bad. Whatever >> that should be it
is thank you bad. Thank you guys. >> Um is that relevant
to your court case in court? Uh, nope. Because of the way that
Pixie and the rest of the people did it. Um, she gave them like
just enough stuff to attack me and all of these peripheral communities
that she doesn't have to directly interact.
>> Why is he pretending? Like, what do you mean? She gave
them just enough is out in the public. Uh, Aby's out in the public.
Cherry's out in the public. Pixie is out in the public. What
are we What are we doing here? There's all of these people saying
you violate consent perpet like habitually. There's so many people
There's so many people with. Although she does, right? Um, that
one leak from Justical showed that she and him are in direct
contact with each other, but I think that they're not going to
turn anything over in Discovery. I'm fully confident that she's
going to lie about her connection with all these people, and
I'm not going to get to see anything there. We'll see what she
actually turns over when they >> I Dude, just all I'll
say on this is if they're not turning anything over in Discovery
at all, that would probably be bad for them, right? By the way,
>> oh yeah, I don't think that was a leak at all. That
was like them just saying that was Yeah, that we're talking But
I talked about that. I don't think it's a leak at all. >> Um,
when all the rulings come through, but yeah, I I Yeah.
>> Uh, no, Junarch. That's way that's different. They're
totally different >> Great circle of meanings. >> False.
Um, whatever. Yeah. So, so that's the thread is the tanky or
not discourse and whether all communists or all socialists are
tankers or should be considered as such or those who use the
label should be considered as such. Then there's the threat of
um, do these people
demash disproportionate to what? >> Okay. All right. Anyway,
I think that's all the Discord stuff. So, hold on. Let's see
here. So, he got banned on that day for seven days for doing
the the slur. And then he messaged me that from the previous
7day. Is it the previous 7-day that that's where or 3day
Still crying like a child. Go save some lives or whatever you
claim to do for work. Yeah, I don't even I don't even know what
these ones were. I don't know what I timed out for here. I think
his logs are deleted in the Discord.
I have to go and see. cringe personal attacks. He did he did
sign up British send me money to get unbanned before a couple
times. Anyway, who who let this person use a computer?
>> Who who let this person Get out of here.
Hello. Okay.
Okay. There's There's like so much more content tonight, dude.
There's actually like so much more. Are we Are we finally going
to do it? Are we finally going to
the Darius stuff? Oh, I forgot to put this up earlier.
I had a me
I forgot to put this up earlier. They're starting to actually
buy this. I've got them saying Beller Pros. Lol. All right. Good
night. Love you. Good work. Update me again tomorrow. Also, stop
telling me love you. Hassan would never say that. Assan would
never say that back to Queen. What the? He would never say it.